au nom de l'assemblée générale j'ai
l'honneur d'accueillir
à l'organisation des nations unies son
excellence volet numéro zelensky
président de l'ukraine et l'invite à
s'adresser à l'assemblée
je vous remercie
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement des dames et messieurs
il est l'heure de se réveiller
c'est un appel lancé par le secrétaire
général de son excellence monsieur
gouttes rs à l'endroit des dirigeants
mondiaux à la veille de l'assemblée
générale qui nous et à tous adressés
pour moi cet appel est très spécial
pour moi
chaque nuit précédant l'assemblée
générale était une nuit blanche en 2019
en 2019 j'étais nerveux avant mon
premier discours 2020 était une année
nuits blanches pour l'ensemble de
l'humanité alors à cause de lakovic 19
et je souhaiterais vous donner davantage
de détails sur la nuit précédente à 3
heures du matin j'ai reçu des dizaines
de coups de téléphone le premier
conseiller du gouvernement l'ukrainien
est attaqué des coups de feu ont été
entendus c'est le prix du changement
dans le pays c'est le prix de la réforme
par chance je serrerai a survécu par
chance
la vie du chauffeur et maintenant sauf
mais ce discours ne sera pas ordinaire
ça ne sera pas un discours typique de
l'onu mais j'espère qu'il vous
intéressera tous il est l'heure de se
réveiller sans flatterie sans
exagération je peux dire ce qui suit
l'ukraine ne s'est réveillé il ya bien
longtemps
depuis l'ukraine ne dort plus
elle ne dort plus depuis qu'elle a
survécu à la famille du col aux morts
elle ne dort plus depuis que le monde a
survécu à la deuxième guerre mondiale et
l'holocauste qui a coûté des centaines
de millions de vies
c'était
le cri que devait payer l'humanité pour
apprendre que toutes les nations que
tous les peuples étaient égaux et que
tous les conflits devait être réglé par
le biais du dialogue
exclusivement par le biais du dialogue
et non des temps
c'est fort de cette conviction qu'en
1945 que l'ukraine
a été l'une des nations fondatrices de
l'onu
aujourd'hui les pères fondateurs de
l'onu aurait été de choquer de voir
apparaître dans le titre
de cette assemblée générale respecter
les droits des personnes
ils se demanderaient qu'avez-vous fait
ses soixante seize dernières années
la réponse
nous vient de lakovic 19
nous
nous avons tendu un l'égalité jeunes et
c'est une chose de partager des
objectifs c'en est une autre de partager
des vaccins les vaccins sauvent lévis
il est ici question d'égalité
il y aurait une autre en petits
caractères
nous sommes tous égaux certes mais
l'accès au vaccin revient d'abord aux
passagers de première classe l'ukraine
n'a pas attendu que les autres l'aident
l'ukraine à aider les autres sans
attendre la moindre reconnaissance nous
avons envoyé des médecins en italie
nous avons envoyé des équipements de
protection et l'ukraine à aider tous
ceux qui avaient besoin de son aide
lorsque le monde a oublié que la
pandémie était temporaire et que le
monde se réuniraient à nouveau ici
comment peuvent-ils se regarder droit
dans les yeux je l'est l'ukraine elle
n'a pas à avoir honte elle a le droit
d'affirmer vouloir revitaliser l'onu
c'est le cas
tout d'abord nous devons ressusciter sa
charte il ne s'agit pas de
recommandations pour conformité
volontaire
on y trouve pas les mots chacun pensera
à soi d'abord
le monde doit reconnaître avoir échoué
le texte de l'unité lors de lakovic 19
et devrait détourner le regard
à l'occasion du vingtième anniversaire
de la déclaration de d'urban visant à
éliminer toutes les formes de
discrimination raciale
qui aurait pu imaginer qu'un jour
les médecins les médicaments deviendrai
un instrument de discrimination dans le
contexte des discussions sur la crise
alimentaire mondiale
allons-nous un jour partager l'eau et le
pain de cette même manière
j'espère que non lakovic 19 n'a pas
encore été limités un plan de
vaccination mondiale reste à l'ordre du
jour en outre des garanties qu'il n'y
aura pas de nouveaux virus
frappant le monde soit aussi robuste que
les garanties de sécurité présentes dans
le mémorandum de budapest
il est l'heure de se réveiller
franchement je l'ukraine n'a jamais
dormi c'est difficile de dormir lorsque
l'on entend le bruit des explosions et
des armes
et ce dans la région il donne basse
depuis huit ans
en 2019 à cette tribune j'ai dit que la
guerre en ukraine avait fauché trente
mille vies
trente mille personnes avaient été
blessées
1.5 million de personnes ont dû quitter
leurs foyers pouvez vous l'imaginer
chaque année qui passe ce
jeu nous répétons ces mêmes chiffres à
l'onu en
montrant seulement qu'ils augmentaient
d'année en année je les mentionnaient en
2020 et je le répète aujourd'hui encore
en 2021
nous en sommes
à près de 15 millions perdus c'est le
prix de la liberté de l'indépendance
peut être eu
qu à central park ou à madison square
garden
ces tirs ne raisonne pas si fort
nous devrons revitaliser l'onu l'onu
devrait se faire plus souple plus agiles
peut-être serait-il temps de se rendre
là où l'on peut réellement voir ces
problèmes il existe deux des centaines
de points chauds et l'ukraine est prête
à se rendre dans tous les points chauds
et participer à des réunions pour
revitaliser l'onu nous avons besoin de
vérité
tous ceux qui ont de l'influencé doivent
réellement appuyer les efforts de
maintien de la paix de la communauté
internationale
si ç'avait été une réalité ne va pas
d'explosion en afghanistan et les armes
ne terroriserait pas les civils
je cite le premier président de
l'ukraine indépendante
le premier président de notre nation un
discours qu'il avait prononcé à cette
même tribune il y à 30 ans à l'occasion
de la 46ème session
j'aurais aimé que ses propos soient
moins pertinent aujourd'hui qu'il
n'aurait pas fallu attendre trente ans
pour lancer une opération de sauvetage
visant à évacuer des populations civiles
à kaboul
des centaines une de citoyens ukrainiens
ont été évacués y compris des membres
d'organisations de défense des droits
des journalistes
il s'agit d'hommes de femmes d'enfants
de personnes âgées venant de différents
contextes de diverses nationalités de
diverses confessions il s'agit là d'un
véritable engagement en faveur des
principes fondamentaux de l'onu
la participation de 46 heures annie
notions et diverses organisations à la
première plateforme contre la plate
l'occupation de la crimée représente un
véritable attachement aux valeurs de
l'onu et je souhaite remercier tous les
pays qui ont participé
l'onu a fait fi de ce cette instance qui
était appelée à relever 1
défilent à lutter contre une menace à la
sécurité internationale
il
s'agit de principes n'ont pas été
approuvées si nous souhaitons
revitaliser l'onu nous devons rappeler
qu'il n'ya pas d'élus ont cette instance
pas d'intouchables
l'onu est composé de 193 nations égal et
j'invite toutes ces nations a adhéré à
la déclaration de la plate forme pour la
crimée visant à condamner l'occupation
et à montrer que vous êtes
opposés aux modifications des frontières
par la force
ce n'est pas de l'ironie ce n'est pas de
l'humour
la
plateforme restera toujours ouverte à la
russie
dans notre monde de plus personne n'a de
sentiment de sécurité
personne ne se sent en sécurité dans
notre monde
personne ne peut se cacher derrière le
droit international qui servirait de
murs de pierre
si les relations internationales un plot
du nord a implosé n'y aura plus que la
loi du plus fort l'égoïsme remplacera
alors la coopération il y aura davantage
de
dictature - d'égalité moins de
démocratie mois de liberté
qu'est ce que la souveraineté nationale
il est avant tout question de liberté
il s'agit de la possibilité de choisir
sa destinée la destinée d'un individu
d'émulation
je me suis exprimé en russe j'ai cité
une déclaration du président poutine
lors de la conférence de munich en
2017 et ensuite à l'assemblée générale
ces mots ne vous parle est-il pas
pertinente nous savons maintenant ce que
pense moscou
début septembre
le premier vice-président des tatars de
crimée demichelis a été
détenu de manière illicite
des
ce journaliste ce présentateur télé
est
détenu car il aurait tenté de faire
exploser
soi-disant une conduite de gaz c'est là
le prix de la protection des droits de
l'homme
je compte sur l'appui de la communauté
internationale et sur votre appui à tous
pour assurer sa libération et la
libération de quelque
450 ukrainiens qui sont détenues de
manière illégale
dans les territoires temporairement
occupé par la fédération de aussi de
l'ukraine je vous appelle à appuyer une
résolution mise à jour sur la situation
relative aux droits de l'homme en crimée
occupé et sur la démilitarisation de la
péninsule
cette résolution sera soumise pour
examen par l'assemblée générale vers la
fin de l'année
nous souhaitons exprimer notre
reconnaissance se défait pts que
le point sur les territoires
temporairement occupé de l'ukraine et
était inclus à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée générale
mais comment ces territoires
occupés pour est il un jour disparaître
de l'ordre du jour ça nous paraît
évident nous souhaitons remercier toutes
les nations qui ont mentionné l'ukraine
dans le cadre de leurs interventions
une remercions ceux qui n'ont pas hésité
à identifier l'ukraine comme amis comme
partenaire
il appelle un chat un chat il appelle
l'occupation l'occupation et l'agression
une agression sans craindre
que quelqu'un ne puisse quitter la salle
en tant que preuve de leur
mécontentement il s'agit d'une instance
de dialogue
cela ne rend pas l'ukraine heureux ce
qui rendrait le cren heureux c'est que
quelqu'un quitte notre territoire
quittent nos frontières
en 1945
la crimée a été le théâtre de la
conférence de yalta
qui a marqué
la
fondation d'une organisation
internationale et qui a amené à la
première conférence
pour la création de l'onu tant la crimée
que yalta sont maintenant occupés depuis
huit ans comment pouvons-nous
revitaliser l'onu si le berceau même
de l'onu demeure occupée par un membre
permanent du conseil de sécurité
le président de la 66ème session de
l'assemblée générale a longuement parlé
du changement climatique la protection
de l'environnement de la protection de
la nature dans ce contexte
la crimée mériterait une attention unis
de la part de l'aunis cet écosystème
unique a été transformée en une base
militaire plutôt que la faune et de la
flore on y trouve de la marine et des
soldats
mais dans l'âme des cris mais le
principal problème ce n'est pas le
réchauffement climatique c'est la
dévastation
nous devons reconnaître
que le monde ne s'attaque pas à tous ces
problèmes
l'onu a exprimé cette préoccupation sur
des situations qu'il ne prend guère le
temps de résoudre
comme si nous remettions le prix du
principal malheur mondiale
chaque assemblée générale
montre que le monde ne fait que
rassembler ses malheurs dans un sac
et nous voyons maintenant le décor se
fissurer
on voit famille analphabétisation manque
d'accès à une eau potable un air propre
mais semble que tous ces problèmes ne
sont jamais résolus par manque de temps
et surtout par manque de courage nous
n'agissons pas comme des dirigeants nous
agissons comme les politiciens des
politiciens qui craignent qu'un jour
l'humanité leur posera des questions à
ce sujet et qu'il ne faut se protéger
leurs intérêts nous n'avons jamais
promis de d'éliminer la famine nous
avons simplement promis de faire de
notre mieux pour le faire nous n'avons
jamais promis d'éliminer le changement
climatique
nous avons promis
de faire tout notre possible pour le
faire
si nous réitérons notre engagement et
notre détermination à trouver des
accords us pour renforcer la coopération
combien de temps allons-nous perdu 7 on
nous réellement revitaliser le nu soyons
honnêtes
nous ne parlerions pas de cette
assemblée générale comme d'un débat
général un débat c'est dynamique chaque
partenaire a la possibilité de poser des
questions
comme ça
par exemple on pourrait prendre
l'exemple des 100000
ukrainiens qui ont reçu un passeport
russe ne s'agit pas là
d'une forme de dédain vis-à-vis du droit
international la russie elle même l'a
dit ouvertement
elle force nos citoyens à participer à
des élections afin d'élire le parlement
plus si l'onu ne répond pas de manière
adéquate
que va-t-elle prouver est il trop tard
pour revitaliser l'onu je pense que non
il n'est pas trop tard
l'onu devrait aider ceux qui souhaitent
faire de notre monde un monde meilleur
lucre l'onu a proposé différents
initiative différentes attend prenons
l'exemple de la
plateforme crime elle elle est censée
fonctionner sur les auspices de l'onu
et chaque nation
dispose d'une instance à l'onu 24 heures
sur 24 7 jours sur 7 pour aborder ces
préoccupations ce serait là ce que
voudrait dire vraiment revitaliser l'onu
cela permettrait de restaurer la
confiance
en alu
mesdames et messieurs je comprends bien
que l'onu peut faire l'objet de
critiques mais ce faisant nous nous
critiquons nous mêmes le nu ce n'est pas
qu'une enceinte ce sont des états
membres qui ont fondé l'onu il est à 76
ans aurait-il pu
prévoir toutes les possibilités non ré
t-il pu imaginer que le droit de veto
deviendrait un symbole qui permettrait à
une nation
de faire de ce droit un outil de
chantage
nous devons tous retrouver foi en nous
mêmes
l'onu a entendu nombre de critiques
d'accusations selon lesquelles elle
n'était pas capable d'agir
certains disent même que l'onu est
devenue une autre ligue des nations
l'onu est un super héros qui a oublié
tout son pouvoir il peut avoir
l'impression d'être affaiblie de la même
manière
qu'une personne âgée pourrait avoir
l'impression d'avoir perdu ses plus
beaux jours en 1991
près d'un milliard de personnes ont eu
accès pour la première fois à l'eau
potable
chacun
alors aussi des droits qui a consacré
pour la première fois les droits de
l'homme qui a apporté l'eau potable à
des personnes dans 83 pays du monde qui
a été
chef de file des efforts visant à
éliminer des phénomènes tels que
l'apartheid eagles
d'où viennent les casques bleus qui ont
assuré la paix dans des dizaines de pays
qui a créé l'unesco qui protège le
vatican l'acropole versailles
et bien des sites du patrimoine mondial
qui a créé d'unicef
qui protège les enfants dans plus de 190
pays
ce sont là nos biens les plus précieux
et c'est pour cette raison que
il ne sera jamais obsolète d'appeler à
l'unité
qu'en dites vous excellences
mesdames et messieurs les dirigeants
faisons preuve de détermination
montrons nous engager en faveur du
renforcement de la coopération
montrons le et agissons même sans
résolution sont déclaration
agissons en tant qu'humain en tant que
nation en tant que nations unies
nous devons agir pour faire une
différence sans quoi ses sièges de
meuron vide c'est là le cri je vous
remercie
en lui en provisionnant la famille au
nom de l'assemblée générale je souhaite
remercier le président de l'ukraine de
la l'allocution qu'il vient de prononcer
je demande de au protocole d'accompagner
son excellence
je te donne maintenant la parole au
représentant du malawi
afin qu'ils le présentent une allocution
du chef d'état
où seul président
j'ai l'honneur et le privilège de
présenter le président de la république
du malawi son excellence docteur lazarev
mccarthy chaque wira
afin qu'il apporte sa contribution